star butterfly became a force to be
reckoned with before the first season of
star versus the forces of evil even
aired think you know everything about
this show wait until number one to find
out what was originally intended for
Marco and stars relationship if this is
your first time visiting the things
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up here are
20 things you didn't know about star vs.
the forces of evil do you want to be a
DIY expert check out our friends at
crafty hackers they have the best hacks
crafts and everything DIY watch their
videos for the best household tricks DIY
decor and fun recipes if you love making
crafts with your friends or just trying
new things they have everything you're
looking for
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any awesome hacks and crafts a
first for women the creator of star vs.
the forces of evil is a force to be
reckoned with herself
Darrin FC is the second female creator
of a Disney animated series and the
first female creator of a Disney XD
Series Neff si has said in an interview
with oh my Disney that she doesn't
really think of the impact she has on a
day-to-day basis rather she feels lucky
to get to do what she loves every day
Neph si is paving the way for the women
on her show as well as other animated
series who will have an easier time
making their name known in animation
talk about girl power
Disney loved it before it began the
strong heroine and quirky characters in
star vs. the forces of evil really
helped get Disney height for the
audience's reaction to the show
they clearly picked up on how relatable
star is as she struggles with her
identity while dealing with the added
pressure of being able to use magic and
defeat monsters stars personality is
what makes her so endearing as she
always seems to get into trouble despite
having the best intentions it didn't
even take a pilot to air for Disney to
know the show would be an instant hit
they renewed it for a second season
before anyone else was even able to see
the first star was a fourth grader when
Darrin FC first came up with the concept
art for star butterfly she envisioned
her as being much younger in fact star
was designed to resemble now
see when she was in fourth grade Starr
was going to be a young girl obsessed
with Sailor Moon with a talking cat in
addition she believed that she was a
superhero when in reality she was not
obviously over the years Neph sees
vision for star changed and for the
better we think star butterfly
definitely still has a curiosity and
naivety about her that we can only
imagine makes her as lovable as her
fourth grade version must have been
first time voice acting it's typical to
have to work at something before making
it big edan share the voice behind star
did not have that experience star
butterfly is the first time Sharra's
voice acted in her career used a live
action and her role as sue heck in the
middle shares first time ever
auditioning as a voice actor for the
character of star butterfly was
nerve-racking she said she wanted the
parts so badly and she really fell in
love with stars character she told
Huffington Post in an interview that she
wishes there was a character like star
on TV when she was young now she gets to
bring that character to life star
butterfly was a college creation Darin
FC came up with the idea of star
butterfly when she was in college a
friend of Neff C's worked at the Cartoon
Network and told Nessie about a new
initiative they were developing at the
time called cartoon stitute they were
putting out a call for a bunch of pilots
and the star was born from a series of
doodles of a girl with heart shaped
cheeks originally star just really
wanted magical powers but when nefzi
brought her to Disney they asked what
would happen if star really did possess
magical powers just goes to show that
something as innocent as a college
doodle can result in a successful career
Disney Animation's same-sex kiss just
friends is much more than the 39th
episode of the second season of star
versus the forces of evil it's also the
first time a show on Disney XD showed
same-sex couples kissing on screen to
refresh your minds Marco Starr and
Jackie attend a love sentence concert
and when the song just friends plays
couples in the audience start kissing if
you pay attention you'll notice that the
couples kissing aren't all made up of
one man and one woman
this may seem like a pretty low-key move
but it's a small step in the right
direction for on-screen diversity
illusions in Blood Moon ball on several
occasions star versus the forces of evil
does a great job of including some
references for the audience to enjoy for
example when the participants at the
ball in the Blood Moon ball episode get
drenched in blood this is an allusion to
Stephen King's novel and movie Carrie
when the same thing is done to her as a
prank
Marko's attire in this episode is also a
reference to the Mexican holiday Dia de
los Muertos or Day of the Dead as part
of the celebration it's customary to
wear skeleton costumes as a way of
commemorating the dead
edan share and star grow together in an
interview with Variety the show's
creator and producer Darrin FC admitted
to having a difficult time finding the
right voice for star Neffs he found that
she was instantly struck when meeting
Eden Sher who was cast as the voice
actor for the show's protagonist Cher's
confident voice isn't the only reason
she was perfect for the part
Neph SIA said that cher will often say
something that ends up being written as
a line for star in the script for the
following episode Neff si has also said
that the character and the actor have
almost developed a relationship in which
they grow together and even start to
feed off one another Marco Diaz martial
arts skills in real life did you know
that the voice actor responsible for
Marco Diaz Adam McArthur is actually
into martial arts in real life what a
perfect match in fact in an interview
with Hollywood Life MacArthur admits
that he loved Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles as a kid maybe that's when his
love for martial arts began in the
interview he says he had been practicing
martial arts since he was a kid and when
he's not voicing Marco he still enjoys
training and teaching martial arts he's
also into bouldering so we'll have to
keep an eye out to see if Marco ends up
scaling some rocks allusions to Charles
Manson it's always cool to uncover
hidden meanings behind some of the
scenes in our favorite TV shows star vs.
the forces of evil is no exception to
the rule in the season 2 premiere my new
wand when Marco is stuck in a closet
Glosser ik appears and tries to help her
of the situation in the process glossary
asks if they're in some kind of training
thing if they're mad and a bunch of
other weird questions referring to
wolves this is actually a reference to
Charles Manson who in an interview once
said if they feel blame if they're mad
and if they feel like wolf kabob Rock
bandage do you think it's just a
coincidence let us know Japanese
inspiration star versus the forces of
evil creator and animator Darren FC has
listed Dragonball Z and Sailor Moon as
two of the most influential shows on her
style growing up Neph C always really
enjoyed Sailor Moon and felt that it
would be any girl's dream to possess
magical powers other influential TV
shows include a show about a pink
unicorn called único as well as Buffy
the Vampire Slayer it's clear that shows
about magic and strong female leads
really interest Neph see and stimulate
her imagination and creativity
theme song selection process the theme
song for star versus the forces of evil
was first released at comic-con prior to
the first season airing the public was
so into the catchy theme song that they
began creating fan art before even
getting a chance to watch the show in an
interview with comic book Nessie said
that she listened to 50 theme songs
before picking the one the show went
with the theme song that they did choose
who was created by Brad back who also
wrote the theme song for gravity falls
nefzi had no idea as they listened to
the perspective theme songs blind
without knowing who had created them
cashew the cat the initial concept for
star butterfly included a talking pet
cat where would the inspiration for a
talking cat come from you asked not only
does the need to include the feline come
from Darren MCS love for Sailor Moon but
it also has manifested in her real-life
Neph see herself has a cat named cashew
who appears frequently on Neph C's
Twitter and cashew gets time in the
spotlight in the eight-part comic series
star vs. the forces of evil deep trouble
in which the queen of dimension cats
with human faces is a reference to
cashew star fan 13 is Darren FC one
reason Darren FC was so happy about
casting Eden Sher
as The Voice for star is because she
felt she fit the character so well in an
interview with variety for one one
NAVSEA admits that cher is a good pic
partly because she picks up the same
tone as Neff see which is what she
envisioned for star Nessie herself does
a bit of voice work on the show mainly
for star butterfly's biggest fan
star fan 13 star and star fan 13 our
good friends at echo Creek Academy who
better to voice star superfan friends
than the person who's responsible for
her in the first place
most-watched Disney XD animated debut
star versus the forces of evil generated
so much hype before it aired that it
actually set a record because of the
amount of viewers that tuned in the show
is now the most-watched animated series
debut in Disney XD's 15 year history
within the first three days of the
premiere on TV an average of 1.2 million
viewers watched the show with a fan base
from day one of that size it's no wonder
that star butterfly has successfully won
the hearts and attention of so many of
her fans the best part is she keeps them
coming back for more this sixth episode
this show was a huge hit before it even
first appeared on TV between fan art
after the theme song was released at
comic-con and Disney's renewal of a
second season it's amazing how much
interest star versus the forces of evil
has and continues to generate the first
episode that aired on Disney Channel and
Disney XD his star comes to earth in
this episode star is sent to earth where
she meets Marco and were introduced to
Ludo and mr. and mrs. butterfly however
this episode was actually the sixth
episode made in production order famous
voices fans of all a jar getting into
star versus the forces of evil including
some celebrities several celebrities
have made guest appearances on the show
such as Michael C Hall as toffee in
Blood Moon ball and writer strong as
stars ex-boyfriend Tom in the same
episode in Miu Bertie Jeffrey Tambor is
cast as the voice for stars magic
instructor Glosser ik Nick Lachey the
lead singer of 98 degrees is responsible
for the voice of love sentences lead
singer Justin towers in friend enemies
and just friends
other names that
might sound familiar who've been on the
show as guest voice actors include
Jessica Walter Jenny slate Alan Tudyk
Nick Swardson Nia Vardalos and John
header marcos belt colors at the start
of the series marco wears a green belt
with a white stripe on it however in the
second season marco earns a higher level
belt in red belt after five years as a
green belt marcos requests should have
been out of the question
seeing as how he would have had to earn
three other belts on his way to
acquiring a red belt yet according to
the world martial arts centers breakdown
of the meaning for each color the
episode does depict Marco acquiring
detailed knowledge and caution which
corresponds to the red belt
half half animation in one episode
collaboration goes a long way in adding
something special to a work of art like
any production two heads are better than
one
for blood moon ball it seems that two
studios are better than one for the
first three minutes of the episode
during Tom and Starr's conversation the
animation was produced by rough-draft
Korea rough-draft Studios has worked on
several award-winning animated series
including The Simpsons and Futurama the
rest of the episodes starting from when
star is getting ready for the ball is
animated by toon city who's been
involved in many Disney animated
productions Marco and star were enemies
Marco is always a part of Darin fc's
plan when she first thought of the
characters however his name was supposed
to be solved and he was meant to be
stars enemy once the characters changed
and became older Nessie realized there
was no longer a need to make Marco
Starr's enemy instead she decided that
the two would be best friends and still
balance each other out
while Marco is known as the safe Kid and
star is a world wind sense of adventure
the two are definitely a good pair when
together what do you think are these two
better as friends a couple or should
they have stayed enemies and that's all
for the 20 things you didn't know about
star versus the forces of evil make sure
to LIKE the video and subscribe to the
themes to catch more videos like this
thanks for watching
[Music]